ein live talk habe ich diese woche mit
ina und dennis aogo gesprochen die
beiden haben am dienstagabend wie
instagram story bekannt gegeben dass die
korona positiv getestet wurden
[Musik]
wir werden weil wir eigentlich also
wirklich zum arzt gegangen bin und eine
mandelentzündung vermutet habe und mich
dann auch durchchecken lassen erklärt
hatte auch keinen keine anstalten
gemacht dass sie von corona ausgeht hat
er mich dann noch gefragt ob ich
eventuell auch ein test machen möchte
einfach so bist du ja warum nicht und
dann fällt der test gemacht und am
nächsten tag bei der positiv und denn es
hat ja gleich auch ein test gemacht auch
eigentlich leider davor in münchen noch
weiß geil und hatte eigentlich noch
keine großen symptome ist mir ein
bisschen die nase gelaufen als ich werde
davon ausgegangen dass ich vielleicht
hätte krone haben können und weil du
damals war das habe ich nicht über peter
macht sie sehen dass wir auch gleich
testen
das ergebnis wer bekommt außerdem haben
sie uns verraten wie es ihnen aktuell
geht es mir geht es wieder blendend
eigentlich wie man es hier gut in der
welt also einmal die schöne und das
biest in grau sie zu uns auch gesundheit
und lief immer so schlecht name jedoch
im voraus richtung stil
das macht er war ständig extra damit ich
mir hier mit den kindern macht das
könnte auch taktik sein muss man
aufpassen
ja aber also mir ging's nur einen tag
richtig richtig dreckig und dennis er
schickt sich jetzt so ein bisschen hin
mit peter schmerzen und müssten schlappe
einfach oder
wir wollten von den beiden noch wissen
haben sie jetzt eigentlich angst posi
krone haben
ich habe keine angst aber das schreiben
wir übrigens auch ganz viel auf jeden
fall ob ich angst habe aber also ist
natürlich auch durch natürlich das auch
so durch die medienwelt geht
verständlich dass er heute sehr viel
angst haben zudem
ich mache mir sorgen wenn es soweit ist
und man kann auch krank machen wieso das
leben ist zu kurz was sagen ina und das
auge eigentlich zu den aussagen von
michael wendler und xavier naidoo
gestellt so muss jeder selber für sich
entscheiden was was den weg er
einschlägt und was finde meine wer sich
bildet
[Musik]